zu uns ins studio gekommen ist der bild
chefredakteur johannes wo ich jetzt ja
gerade noch einmal die letzten infos aus
dem handy
nehmen wollte aber schön dass du da bist
lass uns gleich zur sache kommen wir
haben den tag gemeinsam begonnen heute
morgen hier um halb 6 4 6 im studio
welche gedanken hast du dir in der
zwischenzeit gemacht thomas etwas was
mich sehr umtreibt ist ein tweet von
annegret kramp-karrenbauer der
ehemaligen verteidigungsministerin
deutschland die geschrieben hat wir
haben die lehre von schmidt und kohl
vergessen dass verhandlungen immer den
vorrang haben aber man militärisch so
stark sein muss das nicht verhandeln für
die andere seite keine option sein kann
ich finde dass das ein sehr
bemerkenswertes eingeständnis man darf
wahrscheinlich fast sagen ein
schuldeingeständnis einer deutschen
verteidigungsministerin allein bei allem
respekt vor frau kramp karrenbauer es
kommt reichlich spät und es wäre es ist
ja nicht so gewesen dass es keine
warnungen gegeben hätte ich möchte noch
mal daran erinnern an den abschuss des
fluges mhh 17 verursacht durch russen an
die annexion der krim an die vielen
vielen todesopfer bei beiden
gelegenheiten und ich frag mich eben hat
der westen eigentlich seine stärke
mutwillig verspielt auch übrigens die 16
jahre angela merkel die uns mit einer
weitgehend nicht funktionierenden
bundeswehr zurück gelassen haben und ist
nicht genau diese schwäche unsererseits
letzten endes die eigentliche stärke von
wladimir putin landes lasst uns kurz
noch einmal diesem tage revue passieren
lassen was ist das heute für ein tag der
24 februar an dem tag hat sich die welt
verändert ist es wirklich so ein
historischer tag heute von dem wir noch
unseren enkelkindern womöglich erzählen
werden ja das ist so ein tag ganz
eindeutig anders als in der pandemie die
ja nun das letzte großereignis war oder
zum teil sogar noch ist gibt es hier ja
auch nun einen ganz klaren tag eine ganz
klare nacht in der es losging natürlich
es gab vorgeplänkel aber heute morgen
die truppen die bodentruppen die reihen
sind die bombardements die davor
stattgefunden haben krieg in europa
krieg mit dem potenzial einen
flächenbrand zu werden sogar einen
weltenbrand zu werden ohne dass man das
beschwören
dieser tag der wird uns allen sehr sehr
sehr lange in erinnerung bleiben du hast
das gesagt annegret kramp karrenbauer
ich habe hier den twitter auch gerade
nochmal vorliegen ich bin so wütend auf
uns sagt sie weil wir historisch versagt
haben wir haben nach georgien krim dem
don was nichts vorbereitet was putin
wirklich abgeschreckt hätte und wenn man
dann auch noch die äußerung von alfons
meß dem obersten deutschen soldaten
neben heeresinspekteur vor augen hat er
sagte wir stehen hier blank als
bundeswehr wir können überhaupt nichts
tun dann ist das ein krasses versagen
muss man sagen es ist ein
offenbarungseid und es ist ein
offenbarungseid der seit vielen vielen
jahren bekannt ist es ist bekannt dass
deutsche u boote oft wieder zurück in
hafen müssen weil sie keine drei
kilometer weit fahren können es ist
bekannt wie es in den stuben der
soldatinnen und soldaten aussieht es ist
bekannt dass wir mit dem a400m über
jahre probleme hatten es ist bekannt
dass das drohen beschaffungsprogramm
nicht wirklich funktioniert und das hat
nie jemand was getan weil es auch ein
unpopuläres thema ist die bevölkerung
steht auch aufgrund der deutschen
geschichte was ein guter grund ist den
ich nachvollziehen kann
nicht immer hinter militärischen
programmen aber es ist eine katastrophe
dass wir jetzt in dieser situation sind
wir hören mal kurz zu was der
eu-kommission zur präsidentin ursula von
der leyen
dürfen stakeholders can do for health
and target sessions european leaders vor
der pubertät
aktionen vorbereiten wir koordinieren
und eng mit unseren bündnispartnern den
vereinigten staaten dem vereinigten
königreich kanada norwegen aber auch
japan und australien zum beispiel dieses
passiert wird finanz sanktionen umfassen
die
russlands zugang zum kapitalmarkt stark
beschränken werden diese sanktionen
werden schwere auswirkungen haben die
wirtschaft russlands hat bereits
intensiven druck erlebt in den letzten
wochen und dieser druck wird sich noch
erhöhen die sanktionen werden
russland wirtschaftswachstum absenken
werden kosten erhöhen inflation erhöhen
kapitalflüsse nach außen los treten und
es werden die industrie betroffen sein
wir haben vor allem auch vor groß wenn
es zugang zu wichtiger technologie
abzuschneiden wir wollen die industrie
russlands abschneiden von den
technologien die heutzutage ganz
dringend benötigt werden um eine zukunft
aufzubauen
unsere maßnahmen werden russlands
technik in schlüsselbereichen
beschränken dort wo sie sich das meiste
geld erwirtschaften das geht von
hightech komponenten zu
modernster software und es wird auch die
russische volkswirtschaft in allen
bereichen schwer beeinträchtigen in der
zukunft und ich möchte sehr klar sein
präsident putin ist es der erklären dies
seinen bürgern wird erklären müssen ich
weiß dass die menschen in russland
diesen krieg nicht wollen die
europäische union und die nato haben
sehr komplementär zusammengearbeitet und
diese krise wird uns noch mehr
zueinander bringen es ist unsere
gemeinsame
verpflichtung diesen größten akt der
aggression auf europäischem boden seit
jahrzehnten entgegen zu treten unsere
einheit ist unsere beste stärke der
kreml greift das sehr gut und deshalb
hatten sie das möglichste getan um uns
zu trennen aber sie haben genau das
gegenteil erreicht wir sind uns stärker
einige wir sind entschlossener denn je
wir sind eine union ein bündnis und
haben ein gemeinsames ziel das uns eint
danke
es gibt einen kataklysmus sind auch über
eine brutale aggression durch punkten
und den kreml gegen menschen einen
großen militärischen angriff auf die
menschen in der ukraine und das
unprovoziert und unbegründet dieser
angriff ist
also die kommentare sind alle einhellig
inzwischen wärme jens stoltenberg
gesehen der auch dazwischen ist ursula
von der leyen mit einem sehr
entschlossenen auftritt mich hier das
ist natürlich in der tat etwas dass
russland jetzt sehr sehr sehr hart
treffen wird die frage ist nur wie lange
dauert es bis es soweit ist und was
passiert in der zwischenzeit ja richtig
thomas und die frage ist natürlich auch
wann trifft es gut ihn und wann trifft
es
russland überhaupt und wenn man sieht
auf welchen unterschiedlichen leveln
sich die gespräche befinden dann kommt
man ja nicht umhin zu sehen dass putin
im moment am längeren hebel sitzt ich
meine seine soldaten rücken in diesen
stunden auf die hauptstadt der ukraine
vornehmlich auf kiew und
das andere sind pressekonferenzen und
ich hab so ein bisschen gefühl das
gefühl dass dieses agieren
eben auch schon in der vergangenheit
dazu beigetragen hat dass wir überhaupt
jetzt in dieser lage sind denn wir
sprachen vor schon kurz darüber
putin ist jemand der schon auch
diplomatie betreibt aber er ist ein
diplomat der immer unter dem diplomaten
jackett die waffe dabei hat und der
westen nicht die usa aber wir haben uns
diese waffe aus der tasche nehmen lassen
beziehungsweise haben uns einfach nicht
drum gekümmert das war uns zu unangenehm
wir wollten es nicht und deswegen ist es
zwar toll dass es diese einigkeit jetzt
gibt die frau von der leyen hier auch
beschwört und sie ist tatsächlich da ich
habe sie letzte woche auch auf der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz erlebt der
westen steht geschlossen aber mit was
steht er da im grunde primär nur mit den
waffen amerikas selber haben wir dem
nichts entgegenzusetzen und ich denke
ist es eben auch schwierig
das richtige ausmaß zu finden das
engagement das man jetzt wirklich in der
ukraine übernehmen kann ich habe heute
morgen mit friedrich merz auch live bei
bild tv darüber gesprochen und im grunde
hat friedrich merz so interpretiere ich
dass die ukraine militärisch verloren
gegeben ist für jemanden wie putin doch
einfach nur ein signal ich kann machen
was ich will wir haben es du hast es
auch gerade gesagt wir haben also viele
presse statement pressekonferenzen an
diesem morgen an diesem vormittag
übertragen heute auch ursula von der
leyen sie spricht von finanzaktionen
technologien die man abschneiden muss
gibt uns doch vielleicht ganz kurz noch
mal so ein konkretes beispiel was
bedeutet das eigentlich für die menschen
sanktionen das sind konsequenzen da sind
konsequenzen und das sind auch konkrete
konsequenzen ich meine man sieht bereits
heute dass die märkte in russland
vollkommen abschmieren sämtliche aktien
gehen runter die russische
volkswirtschaft ohnehin nicht besonders
gut ausgestattet weil sich wladimir
putin ja eben um sein eigenes volk nicht
so gerne kümmert wie um die expansion
seines reichs die ist nun wirklich
bedroht und natürlich wird das
abschneiden von zahlungsverkehr auch
russland auf den finanzmärkten
vollkommen isolieren wenn es denn so
kommt aber natürlich allein die wortwahl
es bleibt für den moment in diesen
stunden wo auf menschen geschossen wird
wir kommen minütlich bilderreihen von
toten auf den straßen in der ukraine für
den moment sind worte wie er das
abschneiden vom finanzsystem nichts was
russland nachhaltig beeindrucken wird
und das clever weiter das ist ja
westlich und so war hatte gehört
natürlich auch dass das auch
wirtschaftliche auswirkungen auf uns
selber hat annalena baerbock die
außenministerin hat es auch ganz klipp
und klar gesagt wir werden einen preis
dafür zahlen müssen ich hab gerade in
zwischenzeitlich in tenby geguckt der
dax aktuell um 5 prozent abgestürzt auf
unter 14.000 13.800 66 punkte also das
ist erst mal nicht jeder hat aktien aber
wir werden es am ende auch bei
energiepreisen beispielsweise spüren
werden da hast du vollkommen recht
thomas und es ist ein thema das mich
auch umtreibt wie eigentlich die
deutsche wirtschaft sich gegenüber den
despoten östlich europas aufgestellt hat
wir sehen das happy end also das
irgendwie miteinander umgehen und runter
spielen ja auch in bezug auf china sehr
stark es gibt in diesem land keinen
einzigen konzern der nicht auf seiner
webseite einen langen text hat über alle
wichtigen modernen themen diversität
nachhaltigkeit und so weiter unsere
werte die werte des unternehmens bitte
nicht missverstehen das ist auch wichtig
aber wie positionieren sich deutsche
konzernchefs jetzt in diesen stunden wer
verurteilt klar wladimir putin wer ist
bereit auf geschäfte in russland zu
verzichten wer verurteilt im übrigen
auch die aggression von china die hier
sekundär aber doch auch mit reinspielen
da würde ich mir viel mehr harte kante
wünschen von allen wie in deutschland
was zu sagen haben von konzernchefs auch
von influence on von instagram models
alle leute die publikum erreichen findet
sind jetzt in der pflicht ganz klar
position zu beziehen so wie man es bei
anderen themen wie charlie
antony aus gutem grund und mit der
besten absicht und oft auch vollkommen
richtig auch gemacht aber diese bewegung
fängt an ich habe es gar nur noch
gesehen bei instagram es gibt wirklich
sehr sehr viele leute die sich mit den
menschen in der ukraine gerade
solidarisieren wir haben auch bilder
eben gezeigt vom brandenburger tor dort
wollten sich ursprünglich 50 menschen
versammeln es sind hunderte geworden die
dort demonstrieren vielen vielen dank
johannes bühl für diese einschätzung
heute